these rocks these caves where else can
you shine a light for no humans been
there's nowhere else left on the planet
to explore it is the last unexplored
territory in the world espírito salah
the mother of all caves trust me you're
gonna love this what could possibly go
wrong diving in caves some come for fame
and fortune you're not gonna set any
records without me
others to chase history your old man is
the most respected Explorer in the world
because he's got nothing else is a good
kid Frank you need to go easy on exactly
what I don't need to do this toy will
kill you in a heartbeat but one mistake
in Earth's inner sanctum my god could
you look at that and no one will ever
know you were even here so what the hell
was that
I gotta get happy here we follow the
river all the way to the oxen this way
you sure know
I'll see you on the other side Kota
picked a better choice of words we will
find a way out
we're running out of time
never keep up no matter what happens you
never ever give up sanctum